i've walked you through the fire
multiple times multiple times why no you
lied to me in [ __ ] mexico whoa what
did i lie about what i lied to you about
because everyone called me don't get me
[ __ ]
liquor right and you would bring me a
drink go get i'll get what you drink
what about what's about to happen is
great please tell me yeah no this is
going to be another great message thing
yeah this is why i've never backfired
with you
i feel like when you tell a story with
an accusation yeah tell him what
happened in mexico in mexico okay yeah
everyone yeah
look at this face dude this acting
brother okay okay i'm [ __ ] serious
now you're in pineapple express i know
go ahead let me start over dude
in mexico yeah
all right in mexico all the people we
work with were telling him don't get him
alcohol don't get in a call right so
there was an open bar right and and he
goes what do you already know is to
knock you out and you look at me you go
what do you want to drink because i
don't have the same thing you're having
you went to the [ __ ] thing you had
liquor and you gave me some weird sprite
thing that had no liquor in it right
right what a [ __ ]
wow how dare he save your life but i'm
already in the disease i'm gonna get it
anyway i'm not gonna support it not
gonna support it not gonna support it
yeah if i relapse andrew bobby andy
schultz yes if i relapse what do you
think dude he got mad at me how do you
get back so mad at you for not giving
him like what do you think love is about
this is what addiction is that why you
stayed in that relationship
[Laughter]
i love you that's what you [ __ ]
texted me you [ __ ] dude
you got up like a transformer dude
[Laughter]
bro
[Laughter]
looking
[Laughter]
so proof is in the pudding that i did
the right thing in mexico
yes dude you know why this
bobby's the only transformer that's more
dangerous as a car though
that's so [ __ ] funny watch out he's
turning back into a
oh that's beetle funny [ __ ] me [ __ ]
you're real this dude relapsed in mexico
got mad that i didn't serve him booze
and then the breaking point was
got drunk
got drunk on his own
no you started this but in the hotel
room don't talk about that i'm
absolutely going to tell the hotel room
say it
what happened got trolling well he's
sober now so we're actually and we're
happy we're not using i'm not using this
against him at all and he knows that but
he got drunk he got drunk without me
yeah he went behind my back and did it
anyway because i was trying to like i
walked into the room and then he left
and got boozed didn't you what day of
the week was this
wednesday or thursday wednesday or
thursday oh my god and then you threw up
all over the place right in my hotel
room
and then i came to the door the next day
because he wouldn't answer his phone and
what did you greet me with poo poo
he had [ __ ] all over his hands oh my god
dude but because you were having fun
you're just having some play time
yeah
he answers the door
and then he goes there's throw up all
over the chairs
it was insane well i was so drunk and i
poo i don't know why there was poo
everywhere i poo all over my hands vomit
i had a vomit beard and i came i go i
pull
yeah he's like we gotta go we gotta go
home we gotta go you guys we left mexico
we that was that that was our second to
last night second to last night we had
to do one more show yeah yeah we got
them there for the last show yeah but my
show was good it was the money
you know it was funny though he that was
the last day he ever [ __ ] her i mean
he knew
that was it that was it it doesn't get
lower i think he did it on purpose it
does but
yeah i just think he knew it was over i
think i knew it was over i got i can't
continue because i don't want to lose
everything
oh yeah yeah yeah you could just feel
things just slipping away and then when
i get real serious with him
it's okay andy
nothing okay
yeah i'm not a good actor all right um
okay but you were saying no i'm sober
now yeah that's good santino you're
saying when you get real serious he
knows when i get he knows when i'm
actually being serious yeah and then i
got real serious in mexico and then it
was like the end yeah it was the end we
knew we both knew it was like it's not
gonna happen but santino gives you a
long leash
he does yeah yeah he's very pleased you
know what i was very patient with you i
want to say something that is not funny
it's real you know i have come to
understand and feel that he is
one of my best friends
[Music]
[Laughter]
it was i finally come to understand he's
one of 20 years old
third circle
yeah so this man loves you i love him as
well i know he knows you love him yeah
but do you know that he loves you i do i
really do i really do because there's a
you know you can be loved i know and i'm
accepting it
i accept a lot
i feel love here
a lot of love here we do love yeah i
feel when i walk in here i when i lock
guys with you it's like i'm seeing like
an old army veteran like we're in war
together against against yeah
[Laughter]
how bad of a soldier how bad of a
soldier would he be though oh in any war
oh my god you guys are so stupid what do
you mean you think you'd be good i grew
up in san diego so obviously you know i
grew up in the middle class area right
with yes courts and stuff like that and
surfing brah and all that stuff but if i
grew up in an area where i had to be
hardened oh brah i'll be hard but you
did it
but you did it you didn't yeah i know
but i'm just saying we're talking about
you right now
you right now is not hard but if you did
you would be so [ __ ] hot right now
yeah and if i was black i'd be in the
nba
what does that even mean you're just
making up [ __ ] if i grew up in a tough
area i'd be tougher yeah dude absolutely
so give me the scenario yeah you win any
war
from the pentagon yeah i get a cell
phone what number is this i'll pick it
up anyway right right
i'm likely right damn likely for
synagogue you're going to war right yeah
i would have to go to basic training
like everyone else right yep yep right
so i would do the push-ups yep you're me
yeah
right
i would do it right mecca's that way
yeah
push-ups right yeah yeah the guy knows
his push-up
pull-ups right
right good core right yeah and then i
would do the wake up do the running the
bench do the straps
the straps no yeah there you go
i would like how long are you there six
months
i don't know how
that would turn you into a soldier and
then right and then they would evaluate
me
right would they not evaluate or they'd
just stay in their kid no they would
evaluate no they probably need you they
need you out there they need to out
there they called but it'd be a specific
task like because of your age right
they're not you can't just
you can watch it
keep going keep going
i want to hear it
i'm not i'm not being gentle i'm just
saying
you know what is it called the very
mature age there's
you can't just join the army for a
regular job you can't be a general
though you've seen a lot of wars you
know all right that's right i would
change my name to robert
yeah robert roberts
[Laughter]
how easily would he be tricked during
confederate times to join the wrong side
like you know in civil war they'd be
like you've got to fight you've got to
fight on our side he'd be like all right
he wouldn't kick back at all he don't
think he is what it is what do you mean
you don't think he would kick back dude
i would go with the blacks for sure 100
percent 100 see the way he said it
sounds
suspicious yeah yeah i'd go with the
blacks what did you say to the coffee
guy this morning there will be
communication problems like in rush hour
i'm not saying that there's gonna be
like a feeling out point of like what
are you talking about right now you know
what i mean but i would still definitely
join your [ __ ]
he gets so excited and the coffee guy he
he he comes down and i go do you want a
coffee good four shots this guy knows me
right dog and i'm like don't
yes he does you do that
vernacular yeah do you do that
that's not wrong no you don't do that
yeah all right so what do i say that's
right
yeah you just answer like a human yeah
like what if it was an asian why would
you say that
what type of is that
where is that coffee shop yeah
[Laughter]
so i don't know so yeah you're right i
don't have to do that yeah you're right
but he said that he said the coffee shop
he goes he goes thanks dog and i said
don't say that and he goes shut up you
don't know this guy knows me and i go he
doesn't like that he's just being nice
and he's not gonna [ __ ] [ __ ] up his
job by being like yeah and then he goes
like this then he goes uh what's better
if i say what did you say what's better
if i say uh what's a player what's up
playa and i was like dawg
even worse
i know i [ __ ] it up
[ __ ] nervous in new york
you know how old you know like an old
white guy that yeah it's like a young
black someone's young black friend and
they always go like what's happening
boys like that's exactly what he does
he's like are you guys hip-hopping this
weekend
where's the roof i do that
i do this
it's
insane yeah yeah but maybe i love daring
maybe it's endearing maybe
i do i i i feel it oh bro yeah yeah i
mean i'm likable i'm cute yeah you know
what i mean yeah yeah i'm forever cute
non-threatening i'm still not
threatening
so it's like i can do whatever i want
you kind of can't yeah i don't get away
with a lot what you get away with a lot
i do get a yeah like on stage i can show
my dick that everyone's fine
maybe they just don't see it
it's a juice
tension between these two i love it so
[ __ ] so awesome it's phenomenal ugh
what's so aggressive akash is just
waiting in a bunker and just
he's just lobbing over it
i got too many unresponsive text
messages yeah but welcome to the club
though i'm really upset about that i
know but i might not get better that's
why am i not getting better he is but
but that's what he's been doing for
years and years and years and years it's
like that's the thing we've tried to
work on it it doesn't matter he just i
am so much getting better at it you are
and i've been meeting up with people now
really yeah and i've been having lunch
and dinners with people dates you've
been going on dates no not really he
came to dinner last night which is huge
because usually yeah i don't ever go to
he had a friend in town i went to dinner
i normally would not not go you came
here with a girl that was pretty cool
yeah you brought a girl you're a friend
and uh
she's a nice lady see where that
happened and um i i don't like that you
think i'm the only one doing this by the
way what do you mean i don't like that
he says [ __ ] and you're just like yeah
whatever and then i'm i'm i'm i'm b
you're attacking i'm not i'm
you're doing this
in a way out of love i'm doing out of
luck you are doing it andrew's an ally
he's an ally i'm an ally he's wearing
he's wearing the uniform look i am
i told you earlier i put this on for you
yeah what rank is that you know right
what is that what am i am i a
you're you're you're a sergeant am i
saying yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah oh oh
dude in the ming dynasty i thought i was
always yeah yeah yeah
okay um that's racist that you would
assume that it had anything to do with
you if you had a dynasty though if you
were the king emperor would you have
concubines no
you wouldn't have any no look look
around
what do you think this show is that's
right you have concubines they're right
here right now yeah no we we rule
together as a collective but but but
fast but but
that's not that's nice
in this in this crew of you guys are
playing centipede he decides where our
predictive rule is listen if we're
[Applause]
i think mark is hilarious and when they
say that he's the caleb presley guy i'm
like
i'm like that's not fair to caleb
presley do you know what i'm saying like
caleb
what's up he's bar stool no he's more
gagging than there's the barstool guy
but yeah this is a collector
i know i know